alors avant de nous séparer boutros
boutros ghali j'ai ouvert une interview
technicolor
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
quand je vois la photo de sharon stone
qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
vous donc quand je vois la différence de
la communauté internationale à l'égard
de ce qui se passe en palestine en ce
moment qu'est ce qu'ils vont en bleu de
peur le de peur quand j'ai des
cauchemars la nuit et que je vois chalon
dans mon cauchemar qu'est ce qui vous
rend rose de bonheur quand on a trouvé
une solution à un conflit quand on était
à jérusalem quand on a pu signer un
accord de paix
quand on a mis fin à une guerre terrible
au mozambique
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire jaune ce
qui me fait rire jaune ou parfois la
peur d'un certain butt 1-1 ap
si en bout
berthelot c'est venu
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous une autre jolie dame de voir